ah yes uh this Facebook thing is crazy
stock is just down hey who would have
thought that people didn't want to be in
the metaverse I wouldn't know actually I
wouldn't know because [ __ ]
dorks can always surprise you
you know what I'm talking about magic
the Gathering oh really I swear that
much
the Power Rangers Empire ah swear to
Saban is worth how much
I don't know dorks will trick you you'd
be like who watches that and then oh
dorks come through like the [ __ ]
first scene in Troy
actually it makes me laugh but
don't walk into our world and move out
and walk into the Earth
do you know what I'm talking about
just it makes me laugh that people don't
but dork said meta metaverse uh
doors go like this we'd rather be losers
in real life than winners and fake ones
gotta hand it to them dorks dude my
buddy's trying to get me to get real
estate in the metaverse and I keep
trying to blow them off like okay maybe
hey let me come over let's talk about
the metaverse I don't want a condo in
the metaverse
I don't even have coins
who would have thunk that nfts the their
people who have been purchasing nfts it
was a hot commodity for a while and it
went down sales of nfts went down 97
97 people are not buying nfts that's
[ __ ] rappers and Justin Bieber
they're just like okay we did it now
what
nfts
that's the nft stands for no [ __ ]
that I'm not buying it that's what it
stands for dude
no more
not for this guy that's what nft stands
for now not for this guy anymore
snork mad humor but you know dude
it's the whole thing about putting on a
[ __ ] helmet you don't want to have to
put on a helmet that's where the
metaverse is [ __ ] you don't want to have
to put up if I could hook in blue
toothically with just my body okay if I
could just go like this
and then hook in with the Bluetooth and
then all of a sudden I see condos that
I'm in that I purchase with Bitcoin or
[ __ ] ethereum whatever the [ __ ]
then okay but if I got to put on a
helmet and just sit on a [ __ ] couch
eating Funyuns when I know that there's
actually people outside maybe living a
better life but I got a helmet on
dealing with rashes and [ __ ] dude I
gotta you gotta meta the metaverse ain't
ready they're not ready
until
I can hook in with my Bluetooth on my
human body without having to do [ __ ] I'm
not talking about give me the aux cord
I'll do it through my anus I'm talking
about straight up hooking in Bluetooth
thickly
then fine I'll be royal as [ __ ] I'll
start my own metaverse I'm the only one
in there Royal with just some [ __ ]
you know Bots
bleep it out
just straight give me a royal OTP HJ
you know what I mean oh hey dude hey
where's Chris just sit like this just
like this at Peet's Coffee where's Chris
oh he's getting a royal OTP HJ where's
Chris oh he's just hooked in but he's
not even the aux cord isn't he he's got
no wire tail what's that mean that's
what we use as [ __ ] aux cord in the
anus oh what's going on he's hooking in
through Bluetooth dude what's he doing
he's at his condo in [ __ ] Narnia just
hooked in getting Royal out to pH Chase
dude
we got the [ __ ] meta Kim Kardashian
just rub an incredulum tip or whatever
the [ __ ]
calling just
we got the meta we got the meta [ __ ]
Kim Kardashian just working his frenulum
tip dude
over some denim
hell yeah dude this is why you listen to
this but who would have thought putting
on a helmet and walking around trying to
find out who else is in the metaverse
made meta AKA Facebook stock went down
dude come to me meta when I can hook in
Bluetooth and get Royal OTP H Shades in
my Miami condo
with the meta Kim Kardashian working my
frenulum gland
but you know I'm right though right
but you know I'm right but yeah he
shouldn't talk about stuff that's so
dirty but it's not dirty because we're
in the metaverse it's not even really
happening dude
I'm clean as [ __ ] and this is what I'm
talking about NPR should be talking
about this
you want to listen to all your other
podcasts talk about you know oh you know
oh I listen to this [ __ ] I listen to
that [ __ ] all the other comedy podcasts
the other comedy podcast go to them for
comedy but you want the real [ __ ] you
want the raw [ __ ] you want the real the
[ __ ] where we will be talking about
Facebook stock and all of a sudden be
talking about
sitting Royal
in a Narnia condo condo
getting worked by
getting absolutely handled by the
metaverse
Kim Kardashian
just tooling around with your frenulum
gland
where you at MPR
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]